hi guys i'm rahul from simply learn and
today i'm going to tell you how you can
become a successful data scientist now
before i begin let me give you an
example
share at home and you're bored and you
feel like watching a tv show or a movie
then you get on netflix you scroll
through all the tv shows and movies that
they offer then you recommended the
latest season of daredevil because
you've seen shows similar
we all enjoy building shows on netflix
but do you actually know how much of
data science is used along with netflix
netflix analyzes the user's behavior
from hundreds of different tv shows and
movies to create the best
recommendations
for everyone they measure user
engagement and retention on various
shows now
currently they're even applying advanced
metrics that include when you pause
rewind a password that's when you see
something really cool and you want to
watch it again
what day you watch the content for
example some days you feel like watching
a comedy show sometimes
drama and so on when and why you leave
the content when you stop watching a
show why did you stop
what time you watch which content
children tend to watch in the morning
and adults when they return from work
from where you watch in the world
searches for the show the ratings given
browsing and scrolling behavior and what
device you watch the program on
netflix uses data science to show better
movie and show recommendations at the
same time creating better shows for the
users
there are 33 million different versions
of netflix says joris evers who's the
director of global communications
netflix at the moment has more than 125
million users worldwide which means on
average only four people get the same
iteration of netflix this is because
of all the personalization that is done
to suit the user's needs
or did you also know that the popular
show house of cards was created
completely using data science and big
data this was using the advanced metrics
that i mentioned earlier
netflix collected user data from another
show called the west wing from this they
took into consideration where people
rebound a particular scene
when they fast forwarded and when they
stopped watching the show with this they
were able to create what they believed
was a perfectly engrossing show
data science is the area of study which
involves extracting knowledge
from all the data that you can gather
now that you understood what data
science is let's talk about what a data
scientist does
we'll go through all the skills that are
required by a data scientist
a data scientist needs to have the
following seven skills
database knowledge statistics
programming tools
data wrangling machine learning big data
and data visualization let's go one by
one
skill number one database knowledge
gaining database knowledge is required
to store and analyze data
oracle database sql server mysql and
teradata are some of the tools that are
required
for this skill number two statistics
learning statistics probability and
mathematical analysis
statistics is the science concerned with
developing and studying methods for
collecting
analyzing interpreting and presenting
empirical data skill number three
programming mastering one programming
language
programming tools such as r python and
sas are very important to perform
analytics and data r is a free software
environment for statistical computing
and graphics it supports most machine
learning algorithms for data analytics
like regression association clustering
and so on python is an open source
general purpose programming language and
libraries such as numpy and scipy are
used in data science sas can mine
alter manage and retrieve data from a
variety of sources
it can also perform statistical analysis
on the data skill number four data
wrangling learning how to wrangle data
data wrangling involves cleaning data
manipulating data and organizing the
data some of the tools that are used
are r python flume and scoop skill
number five machine learning
to master the concepts of machine
learning machine learning provides
systems the ability to automatically
learn
and improve with experience without
being actually programmed to do that
machine learning can be achieved
through a number of different algorithms
like regression nav base
svm k-means clustering knn decision tree
just to name a few
skin number six big data having working
knowledge of big data tools big data is
a term that is used to describe large
and complex data that cannot be dealt
with with traditional data processing
software some of the tools that are used
or softwares that are used are apache
spark hadoop talent
tableau splunk and so on number seven
data visualization to develop the
ability to visualize results data
visualization
involves integrating different data sets
analyzing models and visualizing them
in the form of diagrams charts and
graphs some of the tools or softwares
that are used
are tableau click view power bi and
google data studio
let's talk about some of the job roles
in data science we have data scientists
data engineer data architect data
analyst business analyst and data
administrator
let's go one by one data scientist a
data scientist earns around 120
000 us dollars per year and these are
their responsibilities to create
data-driven business solutions and
analytics drive optimization and
improvement of product development to
use predictive modeling to increase and
optimize customer experience revenue
generation
targeting and so on and coordinating
with different functional teams to
implement models and monitor their
outcomes
data engineer a data engineer earns
around 130
000 us dollars per year some of the
responsibilities are assembling large
complex data sets to identify
design and implement internal process
improvements to build infrastructure
required for optimal extraction
transformation and loading of data to
build analytics tools that utilize the
data pipeline
data architect a data architect earns
around 112
000 us dollars per year and these are
their responsibilities to develop
database solutions to install and
configure information systems to analyze
structural requirements for new software
and applications to migrate data from
legacy systems to new solutions
data analyst a data analyst answer of 65
000 us dollars per year and these are
the responsibilities
to interpret data and analyze results
using statistical techniques to acquire
data from primary or secondary data
sources and maintaining databases to
develop and maintain data analyses
data collection systems and other
strategies working with management to
prioritize business and information
needs
business analyst a business analyst
earns around 70 000 us dollars per year
and these are the responsibilities to
assist the business with planning and
monitoring eliciting and organizing
requirements
validating the resource requirements and
developing cost to estimate models
creating informative actionable and
repeatable reporting data administrator
a data administrator earns around 54 000
us dollars per year and these are the
responsibilities
assisting in database design and
updating existing databases
setting up and testing new database and
data handling systems sustaining the
security and integrity of data
and creating complex query definitions
that allow data to be extracted
now let's talk about some of the various
skills that are required for the job
it's very important that a data analyst
has
a sound knowledge in programming tools
data visualization communication
and data wrangling a data architect
needs to know a lot about programming
tools database knowledge
statistics mathematics and linear
algebra a data engineer must be good
with programming tools database
knowledge data wrangling and software
engineering
business analyst needs to be good at
data visualization and communication
statistics data wrangling and machine
learning a data administrator needs to
be good with programming tools database
knowledge and data wrangling now however
data scientist needs to be good at
programming tools data visualization
database knowledge
statistics data wrangling and machine
learning they also need to know
a good amount of knowledge on software
engineering mathematics and linear
algebra which means you basically need
to know everything about the data this
goes to show that being a data scientist
isn't easy
but it also cements why it is one of the
most lucrative jobs in data science
now simply learn also provides
certifications in data science
it provides a data science certification
which is a master's program
under this program we have courses in
data science with sas training data
science certification training with our
programming
big data hadoop and spark developer data
science with python business analytics
with excel
machine learning deep learning with
tensorflow we also have an integrated
program in big data and data science
which is also a master's program now i
hope this video has inspired you to take
up a career as a data scientist i hope
you found this video helpful and
informative thank you for watching this
video and stay tuned for more from
simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here